I have many more things to say to you
but you cannot bear them at this present
time but when he the spirit of truth
comes he will guide you into all Truth
for he will not speak on his own but
whatever he hears he will speak and he
will disclose to you what is to
come okay now you see there are many
things I want to share with you you
can't handle them so what do they have
to wait
for gota wait for the spirit to come
that now you got it right what he say
yeah when he comes and he came on
Pentecost then he'll reveal things that
you can't handle now right yeah now let
me give you examples of
commands that the spirit gave to the
apostles after Christ that Christ did
not give because it wasn't time okay you
ready of course go to First Corinthians
2 first of all let's see what Paul says
who teaches Paul who tells Paul what to
say and what to bind Christians with
okay okay so go to 1 Corinthians chapter
2 and I want you to read verses
9 well skip 9 to 12 read 1 Corinthians
213-
16 okay uh we also speak these things
not in words taught by human wisdom but
in those taught by the spirit combining
spiritual thoughts with spiritual
words but a natural person does not
accept the things of the spirit of God
for they are foolish to him and he
cannot understand them because they are
spir they are spiritually discerned but
the one who is spiritually the one who
is spiritual discerns all things yet he
himself is discerned by no one so what
did the Paul say in 1 Corinthians 2:13
he said we teach spiritual wisdom by the
spirit right not human wisdom wisdom
based on human tradition
right and these truths given to us by
the spirit are spiritually
discerned meaning a natural man who's
not of the spirit will scoff at them and
cannot accept them as true
correct but who taught Paul this
wisdom right this would be all the the
spirit the Holy Spirit right there okay
now go to 1 Corinthians 7:10 to1 Watch
What Happens now here's the answer to
his question if you're
listening what is the law of Christ the
law of Christ is the Revelation that
Christ brought and the commands
instructions the apostles were given
after Christ left which they passed on
to the church much of it's founds in the
New Testament that now in 1 7:10 to1
read that I got you but to the married I
give instructions not I but the Lord
that the wife is to not leave her
husband but if she does leave she must
remain unmarried or else be reconciled
to her husband and that the husband
who said that this is Paul talking but
he's saying that it is who said this
that uh believing couples a married
woman who a Believer should not leave
her husband if they do they should
remain separate or seek reconciliation
who's who gave that command he's saying
not I but the Lord so the Lord when the
Lord Jesus is on Earth he addressed the
issue of marriage and divorce among
Believers right yeah he did he did but
now when the Lord left and the church
went to the Gentiles you now had
Gentiles who are converting pagans who
are converting but one of the spouses
remained a pagan so what should the
spouse do now read 1 Corinthians 712
look what he says there okay but to the
rest I say not the
Lord the rest I say not the
Lord yeah that's what this translation
says no that's what it says Okay okay so
the Lord Lord did not give any
instructions in this matter so I'm going
to say what matter that a Believer
should remain with an unbelieving
spouse but who gave that instruction
Paul did not the Lord I see what you're
saying I see what you're saying yeah
because he's being explicit here yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so who gave
Christians the instruction that if you
have people converting from another
religion and one of the spouses remains
that the believer should stick with
their spouse Paul right right right not
the Lord right right right that doesn't
mean that this command is not from
Christ because he's going to tell you
these commands have been given to me by
Christ through the spirit so when I tell
you this is what you do that's something
Jesus didn't address when he was on
Earth but now I'm addressing it on his
behalf because he sent the spirit to
tell us what to tell you what what to do
what not to do yeah are you seeing it
there yeah yeah so what is the law of
Christ the law of Christ is the 27 books
of the New Testament filled with
instructions about matters that the
apostles addressed that the Lord did not
address but it also includes the things
the Lord addressed on earth right that's
why he gives a promise to the church go
now to Matthew
16 let me show you Matthew 16 when he
open it up we're going to read 15 to 20
but I want you to pay attention Matthew
16 15 to 20 I want you to pay attention
to what our Lord says to Peter in verses
18- 19 Matthew 16:15 to 20
okay so in 15 started from there he said
to them but who do you yourselves say I
am Simon Peter answered you are the
Christ the son of the Living God and
Jesus said to him blessed are you Simon
bar Jonah excuse me because the Flesh
and the blood did not reveal this to you
but my father who is in heaven and I
also say to you that you are Peter and
Upon This Rock I will build my church
and the gates of Hades shall not
overpower it now watch The Promise watch
The Promise here 1819 look at this keep
ready I will give you the keys of the
kingdom of heaven and whatever you bind
on Earth shall be have been bound in
heaven and whatever you loose on Earth
shall be loosed in heaven did you catch
it right what you bind on Earth what you
say is
binding will have been bound in heaven
what you loose people from on Earth will
have been loosed in heaven so Peter
comes and says you are bound to get
baptized that's Bound in
heaven you are
bound to stay with your believing spouse
that's Bound in heaven you are free
loose from keeping circumcision because
that's what they did in Acts 15
right acts 15 Peter Paul James the
elders the
apostles decided on whether Gentiles who
are not ethn Jews should get circumcised
and keep Kash right and they said no you
Gentiles don't need to get circumcised
you don't need to keep the dietary
prohibitions except for these so they
loose them loose them from circumcision
but bound them to other things I see I
see thank you for clarifying that I
never actually because like I said I
just read the gospel so I actually
didn't know what he was trying to say
here that makes perfect sense yeah oh
I'm gonna give you another parallel to
this but to them when they went in Acts
15 the Jerusalem Council and they said
look Gentiles you don't need to get
circumcised you don't have to keep the
cuss of Moses but here's what we bind
you to refrain from sexual
immorality and then the New Testament
with the Old Testament tells us what
that is do not eat any flesh with blood
in it or sacrificed titles and then
according to them those commands that
they gave and bound Christians to keep
and the commands they loose them from
was revealed to them by the Holy Spirit
remember what Jesus said who is he going
to
send who was Jesus going to send to
guide them all truth and make the spirit
the spirit yeah now go to acts 15 2829
acts 15 2829 every one of you getting
the answer to the question acts 15
2829 okay I'm there um it says here for
it seemed good to the Holy Spirit and to
us not only us the Holy Spirit and us it
seemed good to the spirit and us because
the spirit revealed to us to bind you
from these commands and loose you from
others so reread it in tandem yeah okay
okay um it seemed good to the spirit and
to us to lay upon you no greater burden
than the essentials that you abstain
from things sacrificed to Idols from
blood from things strangled and from
acts of sexual immorality that's it okay
so but who revealed that to them the
Holy Spirit the Jesus a Justice on Earth
no because they're dealing with Gentiles
wording Jesus didn't address that issue
because he came to announce Israel the
Fulfillment of promises and die and rise
from the dead and they you send the Holy
Spirit to have the apostles and their
followers address the needs of the
Gentiles now go back to Matthew 18 read
17 to
20 passage that's misinterpreted so
that's what the law of Christ is the 27
books of New Testament
instructions where Jesus gave us
instructions the apostles did and their
followers that were bound to keep that
makes up the law of Christ but now go to
Matthew 18 to prove to you that the lord
gave gave the apostles on Earth their
followers the church they establish that
Authority Matthew 18:17 to
20 says uh and if he refuses to listen
to them tell it to the church and if he
refuses to listen even to the church he
is to to be to you as a gentile and a
tax collector now the buck stops there
what Jesus is saying to give you the
context hope you guys are listening and
learning the Lord bless the numbers
Jesus saying if you have a grievance
with a brother a brother has sinned
against you go and confront him and if
he repents You've Won your brother if
not bring two or three Witnesses and if
he doesn't repent you bring him to the
church and if he doesn't repent when the
church steps in the buck stops there
then the church treats him as an
unbeliever a gentile a tax collector
meaning he's don't out of Fellowship
until he repents so what's the highest
Authority on Earth for the Christian the
church right once the church decides
it's over because now watch The
Authority that Christ gives the church
this is why it's important to find that
historic church why do you think I keep
telling people the fullness of the truth
is going to be found in the ancient
paths why because the Lord has been
building his church from that time
so we want to know what that church is
that was invested with the authority of
the Apostles empowered by the spirit to
preserve that Authority because it
didn't start in the 16th century and
today when you go among the Protestants
which Protestant church do you trust to
bind you to their interpretation of
scripture right you see why we got to
find the ancient church because he says
the church that I started building at
that time and I will continue to build
Bu from that time till I return well
that church was there before the
Reformation now watch their Authority
look at the authority he gives them now
read 18 to 20 yeah truly I say to you
whatever you bind on Earth shall be
bound in heaven and whatever you loose
on Earth shall be loosed in heaven
there's that promise again yeah when I
leave and I put you in charge what you
bind on Earth what you bind Christians
to it will be bound in heaven you better
do it what you loose them
from right will be loosed in heaven
you're free that's why I don't have to
get circumcised as a gentile right I
don't have to keep the dietary
restrictions given Leviticus 11
Deuteronomy 14 because the church Set Me
Free from that now keep reading Look
What the Lord promises guys here's the
promise of the Lord that he' be with the
church in their decisions to guide them
to agree with the decisions in heaven
keep
reading uh again I say to you that if
two of you agree on Earth about anything
that they may ask it shall be done for
them by my father who is in heaven now
guys before you move on this is where
the Orthodox and the Catholic Church get
the belief that when the church convenes
in councel as a unanimous unanimous body
not as a fragment in the church when the
Christians come together in councel and
they are one body Unified like the
Council of Nia Council of Ephesus and
they agree on what the faith is that is
the work of God because they're getting
it from here when two of you agree
reread that part again
sure that if two of you agree on Earth
about anything that they may ask it
shall be done for them see if two of you
agree well what if the entire church
agrees this is what the Trinity is this
is what the faith is
that will be a work of God and it will
be
accepted you caught it yeah yeah I see
why do you think the Council of NAA and
Ephesus are binding because when those
councils were convened the church was
unified they were not fragmented yeah
sadly afterwards it became fragmented
that's where that opens up another can
of worms I'll finish it yeah sure Cil of
Constantinople I'm sorry Council of NAIA
Council of
Constantinople sadly by the time of
Council of Ephesus it was fragmented but
you get it but go
ahead for where two or three have
gathered in my name I am there in their
midst so how much more will Christ be
present to oversee the proceedings when
the entire church body is gathered
represented on Earth right now watch
He's listen yeah
yeah then Peter uh you want me to keep
reading right there from from 21 you
read no Matthew 18 18 to 20 uh re
because I don't I didn't hear you read
20 okay got you uh so 20 is same thing
for where two or three have gathered
together in my name I am there in their
midst yeah sorry I thought I didn't hear
that but that's the one I was coming so
notice what he means he's not saying
where two or three are
gathered in Fellowship he is present the
context is where two or three gather for
my sake on my behalf
in order to decide issues of church
discipline I'm in your midst I'm there
guiding you to your
decisions you guys got it yeah yeah I
see I see so this is the law of Christ
the law given by the apostles and their
followers by the spirit guiding them to
make known the commands that God is as
cited in heaven for the church on Earth
commands found in the 27 books of the
New Testament